let's play one more game i have 80
pending challenges
i'll do i'll do a random so you don't
need to be
subbed to be maybe accepted
but you do need to be slightly lucky
okay oh playing
berserker but with the with the e's
as threes
but there's no berserking because this
is not a tournament game
okay so never played before
alexa never mind
i was gonna set a timer
let's play something
[Music]
something simple and straightforward
that's not knight c3
hey it's banana propulsion
this is just for you
bananas drying from being traumatized by
the tea
thanks for subbing with prime alexa what
does
propulsion mean as a noun
proportion is usually defined as
comparative relation between things or
magnitudes as to size
quantity number etc ratio
as a verb proportion is usually defined
as
to adjust in proper proportion or
relation as to size
quantity etc for more ask me to give you
more definitions for proportion
did that answer your question no it
didn't i asked for
propulsion not proportion
you're welcome
okay so we're playing
[Music]
we're actually playing a main line
the action of driving or pushing
forwards oh
thanks so much for that not so great
molenko
propulsion oh like pulling
or pushing
is this position
okay i have more space can't complain
black's going for the the typical
king's indian expansion
there's a cool idea
which i would like to make work
[Music]
um
i'm trying to figure out how to deal
with this
maybe queen b3
so i'm calculating okay i should be
drawing arrows here looking at queen b3
f5
uh takes and then
let's say pawn takes and then knight
takes e5
pawn to z5 i check and win the knight at
bishop e5
i take with rook and pawn takes again
and then d6 again the king would have to
move i guess a rook can block and then i
take
and then oh but then it takes bishop c4
so i guess the king has to move this way
maybe h7 to defend this pawn because my
bishop's attacking it
95 towards the end let's at least start
with this
are you better than alexa at chess
alexa am i better than you at chess
here's something i found on
reference.com it is possible to get
better at chess by studying established
chess tactics and examining previously
played games from famous chess players
practicing against other opponents is
also a crucial aspect of the process
as is the case with any other skill the
most important aspect of improving your
chess game is to study the basics
numerous books and websites exist that
explain the concepts behind every level
of chess playing
as well as providing an understanding of
the base rules
such as how each piece moves and what
moves are and are not allowed
these books cover numerous strategies
and fundamental concepts
studying these fundamentals allows
players to avoid common mistakes and
traps
and even begin to employ these traps
against their opponents
wait what was the original question i
was not expecting
such thorough chess advice
i think i would agree with most of that
sure this should study established
tactics
rather than unestablished tactics
thanks for that
what was the question
do i just go for this
it's going to be hard to resist
how bad is this
i'm basically losing a rook and then
winning back a piece
so i'd be down the exchange but i have
initiative let's do it
oh am i better than alexa chess
i don't think we've played alexa
let's play chess
let's play chess resuming an existing
game
oh we did play at some point
uh play knight f3
got it now i move queen from charlie 7
to echo 5.
uh knight takes e5
playing difficult level 65 what's ready
for your move
knight takes e5 look at this got it
now i moved pawn from delta 7 to delta
6.
look we're playing chess it's alexa
alexa has a face
sorry i could not understand that you
want to draw still ready for your move
alexa i offer a draw
you can get a single hint really or for
the price of four tips you can get the
grand master pack that includes
unlimited hints
would you like a single hint or the
grand master give me a hint
get a single hint for a one-time hint on
how a grand master would move
as a prime member you save 19 cents
really wait
what price is just eighty-six no would
you like to buy it
no okay the current board should appear
on your display
ready for your move alexa stop the game
and quiet let's play chess started a new
game
no level is 65 i'm done stop it
you may say change level to nine
the board is on your display to link
your account please open the alexa app
alexa stop it
what was it saying
they wanted to charge me for a hint
wow kudos to whoever
programmed that i guess i'm trying to
take my money
i'm so confused and now now now it's
telling me i can make pork carnitas
with tacos and peach anyway okay
let's focus i have a bad position
but i have hope
[Music]
i have some hope
this is kind of a cool move so i'm
preparing this
if bishop e6 it looks nice for black but
then i take and then i
probably win some stuff
okay
oh this is not going to be easy to win
though because i'm down material
basically down a rook for a bishop
so no mercy i am up on time though
and most of box pieces are undeveloped
okay aligning with the queen
um
okay man there's a really cool i don't
know if it does anything
but looks interesting on bishop h6
hitting the rook
king takes h6
and then i have to justify
i guess i have knight
knight b6 attacking this and this
and then queen b8
and then queen here i win the pawn the
rook escapes
let's do it
man that's so crazy
oh it's getting wild
uh knight b6 so it's important that my
queen defends my rook
and my knight i'm hoping i'm not
blundering oh bishop e6
does that work that might work
but we might just be trading stuff all
my time
so i wanted to play this but then
there's f4
and my queen can't like defend
everything
ah okay um
so i can either take the queen i could
also maybe take the rook
take the queen and then i'll take the
rook
wait are we just we're just trading
i'm currently up a pond somehow i mean
i'm probably losing a pawn back
but this isn't so bad the night will
escape
no this looks fine
oh the king is doing weird things
play g3 some h4 idea
or some fiancado idea
it'd be nice if the night moves because
then i'll cut off the king and then it's
practically mating almost
really really
wow
[Music]
a king has to oh i could move here too
let's develop the bishop checkmate
wow that was nice
just happened that was a weird
so i was expecting king g4 this is
um clearly the better try and then
there's a funny line
bishop e2 king h3 and then the king is
just in my crib
and it's kind of hard to checkmate like
we could repeat
i think i was going to play king g2 and
then say
oh no my rook and then mate
but then there's oh there's a cool line
check maybe it's mate
yeah so there's a cool line here
if f4 creating an escape square i play
f3 and then g4 mate
so king g2 it it might actually be force
mates
like it's just a quiet move i get
opposition and then
uh i don't know if black can escape
because this is a mate threat
oh what oh f3 there's king h5
but it's still somehow winning because i
win the night eventually
okay good game the berserker
i i guess i survived alexa trolling me
would you like to play against yourself
one day
oh i
i prefer playing against opponents who
are not myself
but maybe i don't know maybe someday
if i run out of opponents
okay so if that goes on youtube thanks
youtube people for watching
and stay tuned for more videos